economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida empecemos en el líbano
y le pregunto por qué está procesando la
gente raúl buenas noches este país de
medio oriente viene en una crisis
económica de una tras otra uno de cada
dos habitantes es pobre y tiene una de
las deudas más altas del mundo pero la
situación que también afecta el plano
institucional se ha agravado desde 2019
las protestas de este martes en varias
en ciudades estallaron después de que la
librea libanesa tocara un mínimo
histórico frente al dólar en el mercado
ilegal pero veamos cómo se traduce esta
devaluación y por qué están protestando
raúl el salario mínimo el líbano es de
675 mil libras este valor en octubre de
2019 cuando estallaron recordemos las
protestas masivas equivalía a 450
dólares pero hoy son apenas 67 dólares
es decir 6 veces menos que hace dos años
este desplome de la moneda local ha
provocado un fuerte aumento en los
precios de la canasta familiar
daniela y la unión europea advierte
sobre productos peligrosos relacionados
con el coach 19 de que se trata de esto
así pues cada año la comisión europea da
a conocer un listado de productos
peligrosos no alimentarios para alertar
sobre su venta y el de 2020 evidenció
que uno de cada diez estuvo relacionado
justamente con el kobe de 19 alerta
sobre mascarillas otras sobre
desinfectantes de manos que tenían
químicos tóxicos mortales y hasta
lámparas de luz ultravioleta para hacer
y licitar que podían irritar la piel
escuchemos ambas tenemos algunas
máscaras les mostraré un ejemplo acá
tenemos una caja el material del filtro
de retención de partículas es
insuficiente por lo tanto una cantidad
excesiva de partículas o microorganismos
pueden penetrar a través de la máscara
aumentando el riesgo de infección si no
se combina con otras medidas de
protección adicionales de hecho tienes
un instrumento para proteger y al final
quizás sea más para contagiarte que para
protegerte daniela y polémica en ecuador
de cara al cambio de mando nos faltan
menos de tres meses para que termine el
mandato de lenin moreno en dos ocasiones
ha intentado promover una amplia reforma
para afianzar la autonomía del banco
central de esta manera busca proteger lo
dice él de eventuales intervenciones que
quieran hacer los próximos gobiernos o
retiros de las reservas internacionales
para facilitar los gastos públicos el
parlamento rechazó el proyecto de ley
por segunda vez por medio del consejo de
administración legislativa y el
mandatario aseguró que este órgano no
tiene ninguna atribución para determinar
si un proyecto de ley es
inconstitucional o no la importancia a
raúl de éste
pulso radica en que los dos candidatos
que se disputarán la presidencia tienen
visiones completamente distintas de la
economía el ganador de la primera vuelta
el correo está andrés araus considera
que lo que quieren es privatizar el
banco central daniela y el chino aumentó
el número de millonarios a pesar de la
pandemia hay una clasificación anual del
jarabe global
wright iii reich una especie de forbes
que es de los súper ricos del mundo la
más reciente revela que a pesar de las
medidas de confinamiento sin precedentes
a comienzos de 2020 china tuvo más
billonarios que nunca en total son 992
superando ampliamente a eeuu que tiene
un poco menos de 700 y muy por encima
del tercer país que es india la noticia
para el ranking chino es que jack ma el
fundador de alibaba descendió del primer
al cuarto puesto entre los más ricos de
su país en medio de las peleas que ha
tenido con los reguladores en los tres
primeros lugares del listado mundial de
los más ricos aparecen hilo en moscú el
dueño de tesla tiene besos de amazon y
el francés bernat
de louis vuitton así es a nivel o
indicadores o street en cerros en rojo
después de una muy buena jornada del
lunes las tecnológicas fueron las que
perdieron las bolsas europeas cerraron
mixtas en medio de las declaraciones de
la o ms sobre la pandemia y las bolsas
latinoamericanas también cerraron
dispares tras varios resultados
empresariales
para finalizar danny que nos tiene como
cifra el día mil 778 millones de dólares
que aprobó el fondo monetario
internacional a costa rica este acuerdo
ha sido objeto de múltiples protestas
por las exigencias que trae consigo para
recortar el gasto estatal e incrementar
los ingresos como lo van a hacer le dejó
la tarea raúl
daniela muchísimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información económica
ustedes también gracias continúan con
nosotros buena noche
[Música]
sí